qu est ce qui se rapproche le plus au
bon dieu je vous dis oui au bon dieu les
chauves les uns cuisson les homosexuels
les homosexuels gouvernement quand même
si tu te réincarner tu peux faire pour
incarner ans marguerite duras ou marilyn
monroe marilyn monroe un groupe en
question c'est pas intelligent
alors imagine maintenant qu'on te greffe
un cerveau il ya trois solutions il ya
trois cerveaux comme ça qui sont vraies
petites boîtes de choix et dick rivers
eddy mitchell johnny hallyday jeux qui
vont pas laisser du temps pour des
dialysés et démissionne je dirais pas
fort c'est donc forcément pas les
travers et je prendrai le cerveau et
d'eddy mitchell avec ce projet d'accord
non mais maintenant on ne croit le sais
j'ai partagé en deux bon c'est jamais y
avoir une suite
david lansky à la caisse que c'est qu'il
ferait le plus content quand je rentre
un jour il trouve lit avec quelqu'un
ah ben on attend est-ce que ce qui s'est
le plus sont ceux qui trouvent au lit
avec une fille avec deux mecs week insim
avant tout rayon qui se trouve au lien
qui fait pas bon au final le mec tu t'en
fous ou quoi
demain qu elle n'en sait rien donné
non mais une fine web une fille gérald
je voyage effectué avec dépit puis
j'aurais peur surtout qu'ils étaient
dominés co2 c'est une question de nantes
par le mot d'amour que tu trouves le
plus con ella beaucoup hein c'est merci
un mec qui dit merci après l'amour
fréquente un mec il dit encore
ou un mec qui dit toujours oui oui oui
on finit par à paris à l'écouté
alors tu l'a trompé et il te dit qu'il
n'est pas de punir ou est ce que tu
préfères et qui te pince qui te moore ou
quitter pic en partie de mort de quoi il
sera procédé de l'appartement j'ai
entendu parler du vaisseau spatial c'est
un classique dans cette émission tu pars
quatre ans dans un vaisseau spatial
quatre ans représentent eur alors tu
peux partir et jean edern hallier au nom
à henry chapier je compare à bord quatre
ans jeudi signé au bout catherine lara
elle est dans tous les voyages
non plusieurs de mes chats pied